- It's like, two things in here
that you don't really want to ever go bad,
combined.
- [Woman] Yep.
- [Man] With alcohol.
("Nutcracker Op71 No2 March")
- You just hear everybody
that talks about it, likes it.
- There's eggs.
- Is there really eggs in it?
- What?
- Why am I drinking eggs
and milk?
- That sounds repulsive.
- That sounds disgusting.
- [Man] Is that Jameson?
- This reminds me of, like, the only food
that Teletubbies have.
- What?
- Oh, no, I don't like that.
- Smells like pancake batter.
(inhaling)
- That's gone bad.
- Actually, I'm really into that.
Kinda tastes like some sort of medicine.
- It's very thick.
- I miss Brandy.
Do you remember the
"Cinderella" that Brandy was in?
- No.
- It was so good.
- Oh, "Brandy" Brandy.
- Smells better.
- They all just smell kinda sour
and sweet.
- Love it.
- Ugh!
- That one was better.
- This is holiday spirit.
- I feel like Rum is known to be
the best pairing with eggnog.
- This is gonna be great.
- This is romantic.
- Nope.
- Super into it.
- It sounds cute.
Egg nog.
What's nog?
I donno.
But it's cute.
So like, sure, you wanna try it.
But I did not like how that tasted.
- I think the Christmas
spirit came inside me
and I'm full of it now.
- Whiskey was definitely...
pairs nicely with a good old eggnog.
- I'm not gonna go out and buy it.
- Rum, brandy and then whiskey.
- Not to be confused with the singer,
cuz then she would be number one.
("Nutcracker Op71 No2 March")
(whoosh, creak)
- It's here, it's here.
- [All] It's here!
- It's here.
- Get it.
- There.
- I think they got it.
- Get it.
- Yeah, you get it.
- It's here.